[Musique]
merci Louis carvé de nous accompagnéant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
de la Haute Savoie membre du groupe
Union centriste et donc nouveau
vice-président du Sénat depuis hier on
va évidemment revenir là-dessus avec
votre presse régionale le dauphinet dans
quelques instants mais d'abord on va
parler d'Emmanuel Macron vous l'avez vu
qui a donc prononcé hier un discours sur
la réforme de la Constitution à
l'occasion du 65e anniversaire du texte
notamment dit-il il veut euh la modifier
pour donner plus de force à la
souveraineté populaire il faut élargir
le champ du référendum comme il le
souhaite c'est très curieux euh de la
part du président de la République de
vouloir étendre le champ du référendum
alors que lui-même ne l'a utilisé à
aucun moment depuis qu'il est président
de la République depuis 6 ans euh le
référendum dans l'histoire politique et
constitutionnelle française c'est une
histoire compliquée c'est souvent euh
une réponse qu'on apporte plus à la
personne qui pose la question qui a la
question elle-même euh c'est Maastricht
c'est le référendum contre la
Constitution européenne c'est la
question du quinena c'est la question du
statut de la Nouvelle-Calédonie en quand
je reprends P Mel les derniers les
derniers référendum qui ont été utilisés
euh moi je suis très vigilant à ce qu'on
ne pose pas une question aux Français
qui aille sur des champs qui sont des
champs finalement des champs euh qui
relève du du Parlement
euh on a deux chambres parlementaires
une qui fonctionne très bien c'est le
Sénat une qui fonctionne moins bien que
que l'Assemblée nationale mais c'est pas
parce que il y a une absence de majorité
l'Assemblée nationale qui faudrait
forcément utiliser le peuple comme
recours il y a un moment où mais vous
pensez à quoi par exemple par exemple il
est question d'un référendum sur
l'immigration c'est ce que demandent
notamment les républicain il faut le
faire ou pas comment comment alors c'est
une question extrêmement compliquée
d'ailleurs sur lequel évidemment mon
groupe le groupe Union centriste
travaille énormément au Sénat avec nos
partenaires de la majorité sénatoriale
des républicains vous voulez répondre à
à par oui ou par par non à une telle
question si on si on est si on
élargissait le champ de l'article 11 et
qu'on permettait un référendum sur une
question sociétale comme l'immigration
ça voudrait dire qu'on soumettrait au
peuple un projet de loi le peuple
pourrait pas l'amender pourrait pas dire
pourrait pas proposer des modifications
t qu'on peut le faire à l'Assemblée au
Sénat donc ce serait oui ou non à un
paquet complet sur des questions qui
sont liées au fili
clandestine à la question de
du du travail au régularisation et vous
voulez le faire comme ça par un paquet
qu'on qu'on lance au peuple et on disant
oui ou non ils veulent aussi
s'affranchir du droit européen en
matière d'immigration des républicain
alors je sais pas si le président de la
République soumettrait cette question là
par exemple dans dans dans le dans le
dans le texte et oou alors faudrait
avoir une une espèce de questionnaire à
choix multiple en disant sur telle
mesure vous êtes d'accord ou pas
d'accordf tout ça nous emmènerait quand
même dans dans dans un dans une période
assez qui moi m'inquiète parce que
demain d'autres sujets pourraent être
amenés dans dans dans le débat et et et
moi ça ça ça m'inquiète rest donc il
faut pas l'élargir pour pour moi pour
moi il faut pas élargir le référendum
pour moi il faut rester sur le
référendum tel que prévu avec les deux
articles de la Constitution qui
permettent déjà de faire pas mal de
choses que parce qu'Emmanuel Macron il a
dit qu'il faut mettre qu'il faut faire
attention à la concurrence des
légitimités entre le Parlement et entre
le le vote du peuple via le référendum
pour vous a pas un compromis à trouver
oui i alors et en même temps il a créé
le Conseil national de la refondation et
en même temps il a on a eu le après le
grand débat
le l'organisation qui qui a avec des
citoyens tirés au sort et ce donc il
joue lui-même d'une certaine manière le
conflit des légitimités et et en ce sens
voilà ça j'aimerais qu'il clarifie parce
que le référendum qu'il n'a lui-même
jamais utilisé il veut l'étendre pour
l'utiliser quand avant la fin du mandat
d'ici 2027 enfin tout ça tout ça est est
très brouillon et et surtout dans cette
réforme constitutionnelle on a de tout
qu'on a la Corse on a l'IVG on a enfin
justement on va y reviir notamment sur
l'IVG puisqueeffectivement il a souhaité
que l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution se fasse dès que possible
c'est ce qu'il a dit vous aussi non
c'est pas la position du Sénat eu la
position du Sénat en tout cas la
commission des lois parce que vous savez
que il a a il y a aujourd'hui trois
rédactions différentes qui ont été qui
ont été proposées euh
la dernière rédaction qui à l'initiative
de de Philippe Bas en tant que juriste
me pose d'énormes problèmes puisque
d'une rédaction en droit il on en tire
un certain nombre de de de conséquences
et l'idée c'est c'est juste la dernière
rédaction c'est inscrire la liberté de
recourir à à l'IVG dans la Constitution
et non le droit comme le voulait
l'Assemblé nationale l'IVG n'est pas
n'est pas noté c'est de mettre terme à
une grossesse c'est le mot liberté et
non le mot droit qui est comme éé voté à
l'Assemblée nationale donc ça c'est même
ça ça vous pose problème non c'est pas
ça qui me pose problème c'est qu'il faut
faire une exégèse des conséquences
juridiques que ça peut avoir y compris
sur le droit à l'IVG tel qu'il est
pratiqué en France c'estàd que l'IVG de
de Simon veille l'IVG de la loi de 75 ça
donne ça ça ça découle sur un certain
nombre de de droits et d'obligations on
pratique pas un une IVG n'importe
comment en France il y a des questions
de délais il y a des questions de de de
médicales qui sont qui qui sont liées à
à à cette intervention euh volontaire de
grossesse interruption volontaire de
grossesse qui sont qui sont importantes
et je pense que dans la rédaction qui a
été votée à l'initiative de Philippe on
n' pas assez mesurer ça donc il faut
absolument avoir une une capacité pour
que il faut que la loi soit conforme à
la Constitution donc si on modifie la
Constitution il faut qu'on se dise qu'on
peut encore faire et c'est bien au
Parlement c'est bien au Parlement que
s'est décidé l'interruption volire de
grossesse en France en 75 et euh et tous
les toutes les tout l'équilibre de la
loi veille a été défini par le Parlement
si le Parlement n'a plus de capacité à
définir les règles dans lesquelles une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
peut peut peut être déf peut être faite
en France c'est c'est
dangerux Simon ve ne voulait pas mettre
l'IVG dans la Constitution pour ces
raisonslà précisément pour pour pour ne
pas pour ne pas l'ériger au rang
constitutionnel et pour permettre que le
Parlement puisse faire évoluer au fil du
temps la législation que ça veut dire
que si le recours à l'IVG figure dans
cette réforme constitutionnelle c'est un
élément BL pour vous vous la voterez pas
non mais c'est un élément bloquant comme
d'autres si vous voulez en fonction de
ce qu'il y aura sur la Corse en fonction
de ce qu'il aura sur les pouvoirs locaux
en fonction de ce qu'il y aura sur tel
ou tel point on va multiplier les les
les difficultés et en 2008 dernière
réforme constitutionnelle à l'initiative
du président Sarkozy alors qu'il y avait
une majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et
une majorité de droite au Sénat les 35è
ont été obtenus de justesse d'une seule
voix de majorité on se rappelle du vote
du président du Congrès Bernard accoyet
ou du ou du vote de Jack Lang à l'époque
donc je je pense que s'engager dans une
réforme constitutionnelle aussi touffu
que celle proposée par le Président de
la République hier pour le 65e
anniversaire de la Constitution c'est un
chemin très périlleux on va en parler
justement on va continuer à parler de ce
discours puisqu'il a également parlé de
la Corse de la décentralisation sujet
sur lequel le Sénat fait des
propositions depuis plusieurs mois on
voit tout ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire audre
[Musique]
vetaz bonjour audre bonjour bonjour
Monsieur R et Audrey Emmanuel Macron a
donc appelé hier à rouvrir le chantier
de la décentralisation c'est un signe
fort en direction du Sénat oui parce que
c'est pas une réflexion anodine la
décentralisation c'est vraiment un thème
fort pour le Sénat qui se fait
régulièrement le porte-voie des élus
locaux des maires des conseillers
régionaux des conseillers départementaux
pour demander moins de verticalité en
clair que les politiques soient moins
descendantes de l'État vers les
collectivités c'est un thème si
important que Gérard Larcher en a
reparlé en début de semaine dans dans
son discours qui suivait sa réélection à
la tête de la chambre haute écoutz la
gouvernance verticale la
suradministration l'hyper concentration
du pouvoir sont en partie à l'origine
des mots dont souffre notre pays le 6
juillet
dernier 15 propositions pour rendre aux
élus le pouvoir d'agir ont été rendu
publi et adressé au Président de la
République et à la première ministre
c'est donc une main endu loyalement et
concrètement par le Sénat à l'exécutif
je souhaite que l'exécutif saisisse
cette main tendue la main est peut-être
donc tendue saisie pardon tendue et
saisie par le chef de l'État qui propose
de rouvrir le chantier de la
décentralisation il l'a déjà fait le 30
août dernier au moment des rencontres de
Saint-Denis la réunion privée avec les
chefs de parti alors il faut préciser
que dans son discours le président ne
s'embarrasse pas de détails il précise
juste toute notre architecture
territoriale est à repenser
l'empietttement voire la concurrence
entre les collectivités locales et
l'État produit une perte de repèr pour
nos concitoyens et si Emmanuel Macron ne
donne pas de détails hier le Sénat lui a
déjà préparé le terrain oui vous l'avez
entendu dans l'extrait du discours de
Gérard arché le Sénat a fait 15
propositions ça a été publié en juillet
dernier et c'était un symbole assez fort
c'était au moment des émeutes urbaines
les conclusion d'un travail
transpartisan de plus de 8 mois alors
parmi ces propositions on trouve le nerf
de la l'autonomie financière depuis la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
était un impôt local les élus se
plaignent d'une sorte de tutel de l'État
sur leurs finances le Sénat demande donc
à ce qu'il reprennent la main sur ses
finances autre sujet le statut de l'élu
la chambre haute demande à ce qu'il soit
attractif et protecteur avec des peines
plus fortes quand son quand on s'en
prend à un élu et le Sénat demande aussi
à ce que les maires a la main sur le
logement en territorialisant la
politique du logement en leur donnant la
possibilité par exemple de limiter les
logement de type Airbnb ou encore les
moyens financiers d'agir alors Louis
kvet la décentralisation Emmanuel Macron
en parle depuis son premier mandat à
l'issue des gilets jaunes ça avait donné
lieu à la loi 3DS qui avait été jugée
décevante par les élus il en reparle à
la fin de l'été il en reparle maintenant
il en avait même reparlé à l'automne
2022 ça n'arrive jamais vraiment non
malheureusement et c'est pour ça que le
Sénat à l'initiative du président
Larcher a fait des propositions j'ai eu
la chance de de participer à ce groupe
de travail sur la décentralisation pour
que dans notre pays l'équilibre des
pouvoirs soit beaucoup plus subsidiaire
c'est-à-dire que la subsidiarité qui
remonte au premier temps de de de
l'église c'est-à-dire comment est-ce que
les décisions à l'époque dans l'église
étaient prises au plus proche du terrain
c'est une transposition qu'on peut faire
évidemment sur le pouvoir politique et
et cette question là dans not dans notre
pays où finalement l'État est faible là
où il devrait être fort sur toutes les
questions régaliennes et où il continue
à être présent dans des domaines où
depuis 1980 4 1985 il y a il y a déjà eu
une décentralisation de ces pouvoirs
donc cette question doit être revue et
le président de la
République a évidemment fait la loi 3DS
et la loi engagement et proximité qui
sont des lois en fait de correction de
la loi nôre qui était une loi qui qui
sous François Hollande qui avait posé
tout un tas de difficultés et qui
continue de poser des des difficultés
lourdes il annonce des choses mais il
fait quelque part l'inverse en
supprimant notamment la tax d'habitation
alors c'est toujours plus populaire de
supprimer un impôt d'en créer un ça
c'est sûr en revanche quand vous êtes
propriétaire occupant de votre logement
ou vous êtes locataire vous payez un
impôt à la collectivité commune
intercommunalité dont vous dépendez et
ça c'est très important ce lien fiscal
est une est une forme de lien de
citoyenneté on est citoyen en France par
le bulletin de vote mais aussi par
l'impôt et donc la question du lien
fiscal qui existe entre les citoyens et
les collectivités locales de de de
terrain et les entreprises et et les
collectivités locales de terrain c'est
quelque chose d'absolument fondamental
pour la démocratie locale et ça c'est un
des points très importants des
propositions que nous avons faites parce
que nous avons besoin d'avoir une ligne
claire sur cette question financière
tout le reste c'est quasiment la
littitérature parce qu'en réalité bien
sûr les propositions sur le logement
sont des propositions importantes mais
tant qu'on aura pas repris la main sur
une capacité à à maîtriser un impôt et
un taux on on on sera finalement quelque
part les les collectivités locales des
formes d'agences de l'État sur le
terrain et c'est ce que nous ne voulons
absolument pas devenir et ici au Sénat
espèce de de chambres tlurique où on
entend les les collectivités locales et
ben on essaie de de de de de faire
porter cette voix pour rappeler que les
maires en France sont euh euh les
personnes en capacité de pouvoir changer
la réalité des Français c'est quelque
chose qu'on vous dit dans votre
territoire c'est vrai que ça a été un
thème fort hein pendant les élection
sénatorial mais vous aussi dans votre
territoire ça ça remonte ces mer disent
on est mis sous sous tutelle ah mais
constamment si vous voulez moi j'étaéis
maire pendant 10 ans je suis le
représentant ici de de 269 maires en
haut de sa voie cette réalité là c'est
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours qu'on me dit mais loï sur telle
compét on n pas la main sur telle
compétence on n pas la main sur telle
compétence on nous demande on nous
envoie des injonctions contradictoires
on nous dit de construire du logement
mais en même temps on nous dit que il
faut arrêter d'artificialiser le sol on
on on on nous pénalise parce que on est
trop riche parce qu'on parce qu'on a
trop développé l'économie parce que nos
impôts sont pas parce que nos impôts
sont assez élevé enfin vous imaginez
enfin c'est vraiment aujourd'hui le
mandat de Mare est devenu une chose
extrêmement compliquée la laissons les
maires faire créer innover et redonnons
leur du pouvoir et redonnonsleur les
moyens de d'accomplir les les décisions
qui sont prises par les conseils
municipaux alors une des pistes évoquées
par le chef de l'État c'est de faire des
expérimentations est-ce que pour vous
c'est la bonne la bonne solution alors
c'est toujours bien si ça débouche sur
quelqu quelque chose d'intéressant voilà
et donc moi qui suis dans un territoire
frontalier euh qui subit la pression de
nos voisins Suisse puisque nous sommes
dans une agglomération qui qui qui qui
qui va vite évidemment beaucoup beaucoup
de politiqu publiqu national t qu'elles
sont imaginées contreviennent aus
intérêts directs de notre de nos
territoires donc euh expérimentation ou
différenciation c'est-à-dire capacité
d'avoir un un vrai jardin à l'anglaise
plus qu'à la française c'estàdire que de
se dire que on va pouvoir adapter les
grandes politiques publiques que la loi
donne un cadre et que elle soit adaptée
dans des territoires où c'est nécessaire
parce que soit il y a une une une
ruralité qui a du mal à à à être
revigoré ou dans des territoires très
urbains où là on a besoin d'innovation
alors sur le thème différenciation
Emmanuel Macron on a un petit peu parlé
tout à l'heure a ouvert la porte a
rouvert la porti hier à une autonomie de
la Corse est-ce que vous êtes favorable
à son inscription de la Constitution et
a une autonomie l' autonomie en tant que
telle pour laacc c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas le mot qui me fait
peur j'espère just j'espère juste qu'on
évite le bricolage quoi parce que il
faut qu'on aborde la question la Corse
c'est quand même pas l'outre-emè la
Corse fait partie du territoire
métropolitain et dans le territoire
métropolitain il faut qu'on puisse être
capable de là aussi de donner euh non
pas l'autonomie mais des des une
organisation des pouvoirs qui soit
propre parce que la situation de Corse
sur un plan de son
insularité sur la la nécessité de
reconnaître à ha au grandes îles de la
Méditerranée peut-être desun statut
particulier on a déjà on a déjà on a
déjà commencé en métropole à avoir un
certain nombre de de de modification je
pense par exemple à la question de
l'Alsace où on a on a reconnu ça moi qui
vient d'un territoire qui a quielle a sa
voix la haut de sa voix et je suis loin
d'êt loin d'être loin d'être un un
indépendantiste ou un autonomiste bien
bien évidemment mais je me dis que dans
notre territoire on pourrait parce qu'on
est comme les Alsaciens un territoire
frontalier on pourrait avoir une
différenciation donc restons dans ce
cadre là l'autonomie c'est pas un mot
qui me fait peur mais il faut bien que
l'accord soit affirmé comme un
territoire qui qui relève de la
République merci audre à tout à l'heure
on va en reparler he l'intervention de
chef de l'État qui a beaucoup oup
faireagir on va aller dans votre
territoire justement l'IV on va on
retrouve Julien estrangein bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Julien
directeur des éditions Savoie au de
Savoie et un au Dauphiné Libéré et
d'abord Julien on voulait revenir sur
les annonces d'Emmanuel Macron c'était
lundi sur les nouvell brigade de
gendarmerie oui bien sûr c'était lundi
trois nouvelles brigades qui ont été
annoncées en en haut Savoie alors ça
satisfait beaucoup de monde et en même
temps ça a faitître comme j'imagine dans
beaucoup d'autres territoires pas mal de
pas mal de débats par un certain nombre
d'élus ce se sont se sont manifestés
pour dire qu'ils étaient déçus parce
qu'il en manquait notamment dans le
territoire d'anemas c'est venu des élus
locaux c'est venu du conseil
départemental je voyais encore passer un
communiqué ce matin de vos de vos
collègues sénateurs Loé carv bonjour
d'abord qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
bonjour qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
ce de de ce choix de la manière dont
elle a été fait et puis est-ce
qu'effectivement et bien on est face à
des territoires qui en réclame toujours
un petit peu plus dans ce dossier des
des des brigades de gendarme rie
nouvelle alors soyons très clair Julien
Estrangin les trois nouvelles brigades
de gendarmerie en haut Savoie qu'il
s'agisse de taloire qu'il s'agisse de
Saint-Julien au jeunevis ou qu'il
s'agisse de ccier sont une bonne
nouvelle nous avons trois nouvelles
brigades sur les 237 ou 238 annoncé par
le président de la République et à cet
égard c'est une bonne ce sont trois
bonnes nouvelles pour la Haute Savoie et
pour les territoires en question il il
se pose une question qui sur laquelle je
suis engagé depuis très longtemps qui
est la question d'une de la sécurité
dans le bassin et dans l'agglomération
d'anemas territoire frontalier hein pour
les auditeurs ou téléspectateurs de
Public Sénat qui est aux frontières de
Genève et anemas avec énormément de
passages dans le territoir à l'utre et
bien entendu mais avec une organisation
de la sécurité qui est propre puisque
une partie de l'agglomération est en
zone police et une autre partie de
l'agglomération est en zone gendarmerie
donc moi j'ai j'ai suite aux annonces
qui ont été faites par le Président de
la République et par Géral daranin tout
de suite pris la tâche de son de son du
cabinet du ministre de l'Intérieur pour
que la question propre de
l'agglomération menne soit revue qu'on
ne fasse pas faire aux gendarmes le
travail que les policiers n'arrivent pas
à faire parce qu'on a des manques
d'effectifs considérables en terme de
police nationale sur l'agglomération
anemassienne il y a la question de la
brigade des stupéfiants d'anemas qui me
préoccupe énormément donc ce ce qu'on va
faire avec la député Virginie dub Muller
qui a député la circonscription c'est
regarder la situation objectivement et
et et et et et et peut-être proposer
qu'il y ait une 239e brigade de
gendarmerie qui se soit créée à cransal
c'était c'était le projet qui était
initialement prévu donc nous allons
reprendre langue avec euh le le ministre
pour porter ce projet donc évidemment je
comprends les les les attentes et les
déceptions des élus euh ça a été
construit avec eux donc forcément ceux
qui n'ont pas eu euh gain de cause sont
sont un peu déçus ou voir très déçus et
c'est légitime à nous parlementaires de
continuer à travailler avec le ministère
de l'Intérieur pour obtenir gain de
cause sur cette agglomération très
importante qui était en fait une partie
de l'agglomération Franco valaldo
jeunevise et et sur laquelle il nous
devons avoir des policiers en nombre et
des gendarmes en nombre il faut préciser
ça nous roit à la question du logement
et il manque à peu près 20 policiers à
Mass he si les si les chiffres que j'ai
sont les bons oui parce que les
gendarmes sont logés et mais les
policiers nationaux ne sont pas logés et
la question du logement dans ce secteur
de la haute saie en fait fait que les
policiers sont nommés mais ne prennent
pas les postes parce que leur salaire ne
leur permet pas d'assumer un un logement
en zone frontalière ou le logement que
vous vous imaginez a complètement flambé
autre sujet Julien vous publiez ce matin
dans le dauphinet un article sur la
nouvelle fonction de l'v qui a été élu
hier vice-président du Sénat oui qui
nous explique qu'il a été qu'il a été
élu vice-président du Sénat ce qu'il va
faire alors justement à quoi ça sert un
vice-président du Sénat et qu'est-ce que
ça peut apporter au territoire que vous
représentez celui de la ha Savoie alors
à quoi ça sert bon un vice-président du
Sénat ça sert d'abord à présider la
séance c'est-à-dire à à à accompagner le
président du Sénat nous sommes h
vice-présidents près de lui à pouvoir
diriger les travaux euh en toute
neutralité et permettre que l'ordre du
jour du du Sénat avance donc ça c'est la
fonction la plus connue il y a d'autres
fonctions il y a une fonction euh de
délégation un peu comme un maire adjoint
dans une commune où le président du
Sénat confie à ses vi- président un
certain nombre de de rôles euh de
domaines euh au sein du bureau du Sénat
et enfin il y a un rôle euh protocolaire
et de représentation de l'institution
sénatoriale dans un certain nombre
d'événements ou de moments forts euh
donc ça c'est c'est la partie parisienne
disons Paris partie sénatoriale Palais
du Luxembourg et puis il y a une
fonction locale moi je vous l'ai dit
dans l'article he Julien j'entends
mettre cette vice-présidence évidemment
au service de mon département de ses
élus et notamment de réaffirmer dans la
vie locale le rôle des parlementaires
députés et sénateurs parce que de
réforme en réforme avec la fin du cumul
des mandats la la fin de la réserve
parlementaire finalement on pourrait
imaginer que les parlementaires ne sont
là que pour s'occuper des affaires
nationales et que ils n'ont pas de rôle
dans dans dans la vie locale or il a une
décon on vient on vient on vient de le
voir on vient de le voir avec la
question de la sécurité à anmas par
exemple ou dans dans le bassin
anmassien les parlementaires ils votent
la loi ici ils votent le budget de la
nation il votent le budget de la
Sécurité sociale mais le rôle est aussi
le contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
et comment comment peut-on contrôler
l'action du gouvernement si sur le
terrain on est effacé donc le risque
d'effacement des représentants du peuple
souverain que sont les députés et
sénateurs c'est quelque chose d' de très
important sur lequel moi je me battrai
sur je me bat
déjà dans dans dans dans dans le rôle
qui est le mien et c'est évidemment
cette vice-présidente du Sénat va me
permettre d'être beaucoup plus vigilant
et d'affirmer régulièrement que les
députés et les sénateurs doivent pouvoir
s'exprimer être davantage présent dans
les réalités locales merci Julien
Estrangin votre article sur Louis kV élu
vice-président du Sénat C allè ce matin
dans le dauphinet on regarde la une du
dauphinet constitution ce que Macron
veut réformer c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup merci Julien
Estrangin d'avoir été avec nous un
dernier mot sur le Sénat puisque la
majorité sénatoriale le groupe centriste
le groupe LR a perdu des sénateurs lors
du renouvellement de dimanche dernier un
sénateur pour votre groupe et 12
sénateurs pour les sénateurs les
républicains c'est un signal d'alarme
quand même non la majorité sénatoriale
est est stable dans dans sa capacité à à
à
à à prendre des décisions au Sénat il y
a pas de il y a pas de on n'est pas en
en majorité relative comme comme
l'Assemblée nationale il y a eu des
évolutions il y a une progression aussi
d'un certain nombre de groupes je vais
pas dire centriste parceque on nous en
avons nous en avons le monopole mais
mais même dans le groupe de de François
patria le groupe en soutien au président
de la République donc qui un petit peu
baissé oui mais mais voilà regardons
regardons l'ensemble du
paysage
sénatoriale moi je trouve que on pourra
envisager les 3 ans qui viennent de
manière totalement totalement sereine
avec cette majorité sénatoriale qui est
l'ossature majeur de fonctionnement de
l'institution et puis aussi en dialogue
avec avec l'opposition avec les
oppositions hein socialistes écologistes
communistes et avec ces groupes on va
dire soutient souvent au président de la
République avec lesquels on peut sur un
certain nombre de de de de textes
travailler en commun donc je suis pas du
tout inquiet sur la la la la solidité de
de la majorité sénatoriale et je pense
que vu les profils des collègues qui ont
été élus il y a eu quand même un un fort
vent au au centre au centre droit en
tout cas sur des thématiques très fortes
un dernier mot juste le carv pardon
parce qu'il nous reste peu de temps sur
l'Arménie j'aimerais bien qu'on qu'on en
dise un mot je sais que c'est un sujet
que que vous suivez Catherine colonne à
la min des Affaires étrangères s'est
rendu en Arménie mardi est-ce que vous
trouvez que la France est à la hauteur
sur ce dossier la communauté
internationale est bien silencieuse par
rapport à un drame humain on a beaucoup
parlé de l'Ukraine et le fait que les
Américains décident de ne pas intervenir
dans une zone d'inffluence qui est la
zone d'influence de la Russie le fait
que nous ne n'ayons plus de discussion
et pour cause avec le pouvoir russe ça
aboutit à ça donc l'Arménie pour la
France en terme de lien historique de
lien culturel de lien de lien amicaux
c'est c'est un c'est un pays avec lequel
nous
avons une relation très particulière et
il faut absolument affirmer au-delà de
la question dukarabak ou de Lasar
absolument affirmer le principe de
l'intangibilité des frontières de
l'Arménie parce que si demain notamment
le sud de l'Arménie devait être conquis
alors on rentrerait dans un autre dans
une autre dimension donc je je loue les
les efforts de madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères j'aiême moi-même
rejoint euh la commission des affaires
étrangères euh au profit de ce renouveau
euhou renouvellement sénatorial et
évidemment cette question arménienne
voilà on a mis beaucoup de drapeau
Ukrainiens sur nos mairies nos nos
bâtiments publics c'était normal et en
solidarité avec le peuple ukrainien
j'aimerais qu'on voit aussi euh comme
c'est le cas dans un certain nombre de
collectivités un peu plus ce drapeau
arménien au nom au nom des liens
extraordinaires que nous avons avec ce
avec ce peuple et ce pays merci Louis
carvé merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure